yes well I I mean thinking about the
pluralism issues that I was just talking
about the three sessions we'll look at
the ways that some of the core thinkers
and starting in the I guess early modern
period to get to think about how to
manage religious diversity and in a
state in a situation where in the
European context anyway there's a
radical shift and the relationship
between turin between the church the
Catholic Church with the Church of
England and the state to meaning
whatever that is right so so thinking
about the ways that religious others
figure in some of the texts that we read
in CC and Rousseau and unlock and and
also done in the u.s. context so Madison
and you know it's really interesting
there are the documents like Locke's
letter concerning toleration which is
very much seen as one of the first texts
religious toleration and it's very
important I think for political theory
it's very important for the way that the
u.s. difference but it's a really
intolerable except new place and and
democratic process at all much less you
know and I think it's just like hardly
even getting
religions that are even sort of
mentioned at the margins the Turks so so
the sort of big question is how does I
mean the big question is how does how
does secular tolerance of religions
actually come out of these very
intolerant texts and then of course the
second question is what we're like how
tolerant like what are the what are the
limits of Tolerance right we think of
the kinds of freedoms that are here in
the US it's being really funny we do we
imagine our world is wide open
anything goes it religious the way that
they want to be and that's one of the
things that's protected a great so but
to really use these texts as a way to
sort of think critically about that
narrative of freedom not to undo it not
to say that it's wrong I'd say it's bad
but just to say you know you know
freedom is truly free right no there
aren't and you know maybe just I think
that's enough so that I think that's
what we're doing I